[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone I usually get to
introduce this panel this is my favorite
panel this is my favorite talk of the
whole conference as you know I'm a ex
engineer serial founder and this is a
unabashedly technical conference at
least we hope you think so we screen all
the talks to be like super hardcore and
all that good stuff
but this is the least technical talk in
the entire era conference and it's
always my favorite but to make it
interesting this time I invited the most
technical investors I could find so and
we coined a new term we're calling them
engineer angels so for the purposes of
of the panel I want to introduce some
some really smart awesome people
these folks were hand-picked to be the
smartest people I could possibly find
and I'm really happy that they're here
so true T gondii is a sort of relatively
new VC with her own fund although she's
been doing investing for quite a while
Shruti has a cs degree a master's in CS
from Columbia in New York so really glad
that she's here it Tamar also has a CS
degree now he's working at life 360 on
the business side CEO or chief business
officer great
Parker Thompson is here Parker was
formerly an engineer at pivotal labs
then he went to 500 startups and now
he's at angellist
Parker's very technical and likes to be
very loud on Twitter so you can find him
there
and joseline has a really interesting
career as well she was a VP engine
VMware
then she was director of engineering at
Facebook and tell stories about sort of
the first days when they started to
apply machine learning to the newsfeed
at Facebook so she has really
interesting stuff to say so they're all
technical not a very business e but
they've also all started a company so in
order to let them finish their own
introductions I'm going to ask them to
tell us briefly about the first company
they started and how that went
Trudy their demos Arabic that is memory
considerable competencies to Harrington
listeners fast in context with your
social data before paper crap and the
idea of how do you make sense of your
data to help you make better connections
and find more insights in your life yeah
so my first one was a complete failure I
have no idea what I'm doing
it was year 2000 everybody was like oh
you can build a start-up and you raise a
lot of money and you study for billions
and billions I was this Israeli kid who
just came out of the army with a lot of
coding experience I was like I'm gonna
nail this so I built this a billing
software solution for realistic not
really a data thing and we actually sold
it the Israeli army like we sold you
know licensing and all that and we're
like this is amazing I hired five people
build a company I here later my biggest
and only client called me and said yeah
you know nobody's really using this
software so we're not actually going to
pay you and that's when I had to share
the company shut down the company and
actually realized that I don't know a
lot about startups the beginning of a
journey I have a somewhat similar story
I started a social local mobile startup
before before that was a good idea
before iPhones and we were taking open
wrt routers if you remember
you could put your own firmware on Wi-Fi
routers and we're putting them in
physical places and trying to create
local communities somewhat akin to what
next-door is doing quite well now and
people hated it like the technology was
immature you'd get to a cafe and open
your laptop and we'd replace all your
browsers with our screen thank you so
amongst other mistakes people didn't
like what we built and I just kept
trying to write code to make them really
if I just write more code they'll like
it that did not work so eventually we
stopped doing that one so maybe we
talked about the sorts of problems you
know I generally subscribe to the belief
that code wins arguments but there are
some are economic
not would user yeah great only with
co-workers my my startup was called
actually data Phi but it was a pretty
half page like 20 something bucket list
startup meaning you know me and my three
friends wanted to check founder off our
bucket list
and we had the bad timing to do this at
the tail end of 2000 so we actually
raised money we raised a million dollars
like one minute before the funding
window slammed shut in the.com bust and
about six months in our investor came to
us and said listen you guys are a really
talented team but you don't really have
an idea and so as far as we're concerned
you're failing and we have this other
startup over here that we think has a
very good idea email management and
monitoring but they don't have a quality
team so as far as we're concerned
they're failing and what we'd really
like to do is mash up the two of you
together so we have one successful
startups instead of to failing startups
would you go for that and we kind of
looked at the writing on the wall and
said we're just in this to be founders
we have no attachment to our idea so we
said yes and kind of rebuilt that
company from scratch and raised five
more million five million more dollars
and like shipped a bunch of software in
18 months killed myself found out what I
was capable of when I took the brakes
off the train and at the end of 18
months it turned out that like this was
a small dollar problem to customers not
a large dollar problem and we decided to
pivot into email disaster recovery at
that point I felt like I had thoroughly
checked founder off my bucket list and I
I took off that company actually had a
decent happy ending five year
after I left they were sold to Dell for
a hundred and fifty million dollars so
the investors made their money back and
you know and I can you know say that's
on my resume but I spent those five
years in the early days of VMware so I
feel like I was also better off so there
you just got some pretty good odds
actually we asked a panel of four people
would happen to the first startups three
failed one succeeded I failed two I just
didn't I didn't know whatever grass we
didn't I was building a consumer product
when I'm I hope background an enterprise
and didn't realize anyone would not you
know anyone would pay for the [ __ ] and
no one did she died alone swimmers don't
pay for them exactly that's what my
learning was so just to kind of explain
the the takeaways that we hope that you
get from this conversation obviously on
one hand these have all been engineers
who have started companies and I think
they have a lot to share from the
trenches about pitfalls and how to think
about that if you're an engineer looking
to start at your company on your own but
then there's this other subtext right
we're a data conference so we might veer
into some questions sort of about the
future of data and VC is love to talk
about data and technical people love
data because it's a scale problem in in
the best case so we'll kind of ear into
that and get some of their opinions on
that as well since that's one of our
main themes so guys the one of the
things that I realized in my own startup
life especially from an engineer's
mentality is I always want to over
optimize stuff how do you like wean
yourself away from building perfectness
as an engineer to how hopefully having a
snowball shot in hell is succeeding as a
start-up founder you have to go read the
blog post from the bolt VC about the the
juice arrow have you guys all read this
post
he bought a juicer row machine and he
took it apart reverse engineered it and
it describes every like lovingly it's
like why does the juice machine cost
$700 and he explains - so anyway yes
read that post it's a huge object lesson
in the futility of perfect engineering
to solve an unimportant
yeah I mean just riffing on that I think
the problem is like you don't know what
perfect is right like the the whole like
I subscribe to the the Steve Blank Eric
Ries definition of a startup like a
startup is a organization in search of a
business model right so you're going in
with the premise that you don't know
what the solution is and maybe not what
the problem is so I think as an engineer
the bias is to like sit in a room and
just like write more code and if you're
not validating that the things that
you're making are good you just go
really fast in the wrong direction so I
find that to be like the thing you've
got to keep in your mind is like how do
I know this is good
am I making the perfectly wrong I'm
ringing the wrong thing perfect or
sometimes if you're an engineer you go
really slow in the wrong process that's
truly what's active it works right going
really slow it's not going to get you
there most of the time so I've been
seeing this sort of pattern again again
again with you know a technical
co-founder or some you know technical
folks who are running a team and
throughout their business counterparts
and and it's hard you know it's a big
it's a big challenge but but I think
inherently for an engineer and I'm
thinking about also my journey as an
engineer doing more and more engineering
stuff and then moving the business side
I think I think it's a journey right
it's a journey where if you've got the
star that sort of mindset mentality then
you get it really quickly like okay
we're not going to over invest no we're
not ready for a rewrite because there's
no like our wife or that we write
because we haven't found a business
model yet right so so you sort of learn
it quickly because you have that in you
if you don't and you don't necessarily
have that the startup but when you go at
it first then having a good partner on
the product side or on the business side
which helps you think some improve some
of those things especially if that
person also has an engineering
background is just awesome right so I
made that situation as a product guy I'm
mostly a product person or it's like
really are we but let's think about this
are we over investing right and
sometimes the answer is no hell no we
should double down on this because this
is
encore so it's a complicated
conversation to have but sometimes you
have habit I think well sort of two
things I actually data people might be a
little better than your average engineer
because or have have better instincts
for this in the average engineer because
none of us like none of us would try to
build anything with machine learning
without running an experiment right like
you collect some data you run an
experiment you collect more data you run
an experiment you change the parameters
you try different features you run
another experiment like you couldn't
make any forward progress without
experimentation the same is true with a
startup it's just that your experimental
subject has to be real people who might
buy your software like real users real
customers and if you can get yourself in
the mindset like that if I'm not running
an experiment I am NOT making forward
progress so if I'm not encountering
customers I'm actually not making
forward progress everything else I do is
the illusion of progress only encounters
with product with customers making some
change in response to that experimental
data and trying again like that is the
only thing that measures progress and I
think that that's actually pretty
intuitive to data people the second
thing I would say is like you can take
your sweet time you can take as much
time as you like until you raise money
and it's I think a little bit like if
you think about when do we put things in
the roadmap like have you ever been
trying to build something where you
there's just tons of technical risks
like you actually need to invest
something new and some project manager
comes to you with a little Gantt chart
and so I was like well one will be done
is that you're going to hit you know
milestone three for the next print and
it's like I have no idea how long it's
going to take like you cannot put a
deadline on something that you're
invented and so for for research you
don't put that in the roadmap until
you've cracked the technical risk and at
that point you can estimate how long
it's going to take and put it in the
roadmap and and fine look at the Gantt
charts and use those to sort of sequence
things and figure out dependencies so
then so some things you just shouldn't
put in the roadmap the thing about
raising money that's putting yourself on
the roadmap that's putting yourself on
the clock or at least spending the money
puts you on the clock so you can take as
much time as you like as long as you
aren't spending money as soon as you're
spending money you better be prepared to
live and die by by encounters by by
interaction with customers yeah I mean I
think
the data scientists maybe a little bit
better off in this regard I think it
kind of may also depend on the
environment you come out of if you come
out of a mature company that hasn't been
in that chaos mode is an early startup I
think it's a real shock to the system if
you have a lot of definition in a larger
company even as an engineer you have a
lot of autonomy and you're answering
novel questions there's some structure
there we've got a facebook fee we know
what our KPIs are let's make people do
the things that make our numbers better
that's a lot of structure and in a
startup you don't have those basics and
so it's just a lot there are many more
degrees of freedom and so you have to
get into that mindset of figuring out am
i even is the problem I even thought was
real real is it an adjacent problem and
why am I even in the right ballpark and
sometimes the answer is just no actually
we should just like throw this away and
go over here and try something else I
think that's hard because you fall in
love with the things you're thinking
about particularly your like my coat so
beautiful like I've spent too much time
on so just out of curiosity how many
folks here and have either started a
company or thinking about starting a
company cool anyone looking for a
co-founder not specifically so um I
totally agree with um you know much of
the sentiment especially about raising
money and being on the clock Dave
McClure's does something helpful I think
about the trajectory of most founders
and the money raising thing which is you
sort of go through these steps where
right first of all it's your own money
or at least your own time
then it's family money then it's angel
money then it's seed money and you have
to be a pretty special person to like
skip those steps it happens but more
often than not you sort of go through
this trajectory and it occurs to me that
along that trajectory you'll also pick
up team members so many investors are
not likely to fund single person
deniz YC like digs hard into who your
founding team is oh and how did you meet
them how long have you worked with that
person so there's so much stuff that can
happen in the team let's talk about team
for a second you guys see any is there
any common advice that you give engineer
founders looking to find co-founders how
do you coach them sort of our complement
complimentary skills from a team
perspective any common advice there my
those things I invest in are very
straightforward its b2b so usually
there's a desire as a company and the
company is in a particular vertical
which means that you you have to know
what your buyer is interested in buying
so oftentimes when I do look at teams I
like a technical sounding team but I
also like if they come from that sector
and know how to sell that sector for
whatever problem they're solving so it
is important to for me and the kinds of
things I invest in an array to have that
focus of expertise and some of them you
don't have to be added coming for 10
years but you have to know how to make
and convert those folks here selling
things to as customers fast so I do not
discount in any way the role of you know
technical founders and technical folks
in a start-up it really depends on the
startup so a DMA and what you need to
succeed in the vertical that you're
playing yet but to be honest I am more
focused on the business side right so I
want to make sure that okay we can build
this system you guys can build the
system you're complementary to each
other as founders you have the
capability to really make that happen
but for me it's really making sure that
the business plan sticks so I like a lot
to see sort of a founding DNA with an
engineering counterpart that has some
business jobs right when I see you know
sort of CTO co-founder getting it like
getting the business maybe being from
that space
okay they actually understand let's say
retail which is what the company is
going in I get even more excited but of
course if they can build it then you
know that's that's a big problem right
yeah I tend to ask myself what is the
like where's the heart of this business
when I look at a team because sometimes
you see Team Dynamics you start
companies it's very hard with these
people and often their breakups I think
at the earliest stage in companies I
also think about the business side you
understand the problem you know the
customer and often actually the teams
that I fund we have frank conversations
maybe would feel and they look like
yours where your technical team is at
this is not the team that's going to be
with you in five years this is not going
to be the leadership but we're going to
these are you have what you need to
prove the basic hypothesis test that
they step ups and get to the next level
and so where when I look at a team and
particularly on the technical side
sometimes they're pretty mediocre and
you're like okay that's not going to be
the bottleneck sometimes we have
conversations about the gap and their
skill set and I spend a lot of time
coaching coaching technical co-founders
on where they're going to end up some of
them really rise to the occasion and end
up leading large teams some of them find
a role as the company grows that CTO or
maybe not managing the people or more of
a utility player but for me as an
investor the question is can these
people prove that this idea creates
value for its customers and get to the
next level or especially on the
technical side is this person going to
kill this thing and actually often with
the maturity of the technology today you
know you can be a Ruby on Rails engineer
no offense to anybody else Ruby on Rails
engineer and get pretty dang far before
you have a big data problem or scaling
problem of some of these other things so
it's sort of like do we have in this
team what we need to get to let's just
say making a million dollars a year
example and often the answer is yes even
when your co-founder is someone who you
wouldn't hire three years from now
because they're the person crazy enough
to go start a company with you I my
engine portfolio probably has 25 or so
companies and I would say at least 3/4
of them more than half of them feature
an engineer CEO so I definitely have a
vent I mean that's who I know it's my
network but I also have a bent for
technical people and product people in
the driver seat I think the most
important thing to have is
self-knowledge a founding team needs to
do everything like Parker said like
you're not in the context of a big
company that has structure and rails and
anything to depend on at all so you and
your co-founders have only yourself and
I think the most important ingredient in
in working with co-founders is actually
first to know yourself to know what is
needed out of the entire team and to be
really honest with yourself about what
you bring to the table about what kind
of person you're compatible with and
about what completes you and it's not
necessarily about picking the person
that you like but it is about picking
the person that you can be productive
together with I would also say you know
especially in a technical only founding
team there is I've definitely seen like
the sort of fear of oh god we need a
business person like you know it's like
let me have a like don't bring in a
co-founder to be your safety blanket
business person definitely well I'm an
engineer and she's an engineer so we
better bring somebody who looks
businessí right like like that person if
you cannot articulate the way in which
every founder is absolutely necessary to
the existence of your startup you will
fail without them they're performing a
vital function from day one then they're
not a co-founder they might be someone
that you need to hire in six months or
12 months but they're not a co-founder
and so like hiring somebody who's past
experiences like visib you probably
don't need a business person you don't
need a business enough person on day one
you don't need anybody who cannot
contribute to to ideation to creating to
the sort of areas you aren't company
don't fall into the trap of thinking
you're a company you are a team
in your team attempting to discover a
potential market and a potential product
market fit and so every member of the
founding team has to be essential to
that and oh don't don't like don't hire
that safety blanket business person I
made that mistake personally I need
somebody who has a business experience
and this person was useless and we
argued about things and it just wasn't
useful and this is where you'll actually
you can put when you you build something
you find investors they should be able
to help you and you should be able to do
you may not be the best salesperson ever
but you should be able to go talk to
your customers and that actually sales
right it's not tricking them into buying
something it's helping them solve their
problems and I think that's where
engineers psyche themselves there I I
don't know how to sell things it's like
well you just go solve problems that's
what you do right that's why you started
this company and so getting in there
with customers like you find you can do
you can do the job actually that a real
sales real sales person can't do they
actually suck at the thing that you end
up needing to do to get to the point
where you can even hire them and make
them useful so I think it's a great
point
maybe there's a stepping stone for
engineers who currently have jobs
instead of just quitting cold turkey and
starting that first company which you
know I like to put pressure on myself so
that's what I did that was a long time
ago and it hurts so bad
Parker you went weren't you an engineer
at pivotal before you went into PD yes
that like how are you inspired to do
that it was that of all people we were a
whole company of engineers and we just
got too big to all be engineers and so I
was like hey it seems like this is a
thing that should we should do and our
culture was such that we weren't going
to reach out and hire someone
it was better that we might not have
been the perfect sales person step into
that role than to go hire someone who's
a slick salesperson and try to teach
them about our culture fact that was a
big challenge for us when we we sold the
company to EMC which is about the
opposite end of the spectrum from a
start-up and working through that
integration with with real salespeople
was was quite an interesting experience
so that worked for us I don't know that
that was necessary
the way that I would advise startups all
the time to do it but I do think in
general if you can take people inside
and help them grow and put them into
roles where they can be successful
that's often better than just hiring
someone off the shelf and pulling them
in great and how have you guys seen you
or your past experience sort of coming
to bear with your current portfolios um
you probably all have different in
favorite ways of working with teams at
the early stage like what does that look
like and what do you think you're able
to help engineers but it's specifically
based on sort of how we've set that set
up this conversation so far so argh an
array is focused around helping
companies get their second wave of
customers which is once your question
earlier was do post cold turkey or what
but actually my advice is often like if
you have a dying idea before you leave
go talk to some of your friends who
might buy your product in the
hypothetical product you have and see if
they will pay for that down the road and
how much that's before you even write
any line of code and that takes like
some dinner conversation it doesn't take
that long when you do your market
research find out provided all that
stuff but when you do leave your job and
then start and read code and all that
stuff make sure your friends buy that
right but then how do you go beyond your
network to have your other wave of
customers come and buy your product
after that where do you even get those
people so that's what I arrays focused
on and the network I've built over the
years for for being in corporate for
over 14 years has given me that edge to
be able to bring that during even from
the diligence stage so when I'm looking
at a company the the things I bring to
the diligence is like hey I have a
founder or a company who might be able
to buy your product down the road and
let's talk to them from day one and you
know we've chatted about that a few
times and it's been helpful my past
experience has been definitely helpful
in what I do now so I think I'd be
sitting here and
saying how hot awesome and helpful I am
to an engineering founder but the
reality of them probably not as awesome
and helpful there sometimes I have lived
over 50 portfolio companies in general
between people that helped in the past
people that invested directly in
advisory roles and all sorts of things
I've been going through this a lot and
sometimes I can be helpful as a pod guy
you know coming in and sort of helping a
little bit to think about the
interaction between product and
engineering sometimes it's helpful right
but I do find myself spend most of the
time focus and focusing on business
stuff now what I really love and I'm
sort of getting us back to the previous
question but I really love to work along
side you know people that are truly
multi distantly right the the technical
co-founders that get me excited are
people that are amazing engineers by the
same time they get the business and they
can also do pre-sales and I mean those
are the people that that usually end up
being very successful at startups
because you know adjustments that they
can do a lot of different things and
that's what you need early on so when I
get connect connected to that the
founding team that has that I usually
find that common language with the
person who's more of an engineer and I
can help them as they think through
business stuff or other types of things
they're going to accelerate them so yeah
I mean I think as you folks look at
starting companies you're not going to
have technical problems and that's a
good thing right you're going to be
focused on this business stuff I tend to
invest more in business model innovation
as opposed to detect innovation so I
biases through that lens if you're
solving a technical problem where the
the buyer is obvious that this maybe
doesn't apply but I think what people
are not prepared for when they start
companies is how like lonely it is and
hard it is and so you know when you're
an investor and you're trying to win a
deal you're not like look you can call
me and I'm not going to judge you and
I'll help you and listen but that ends
up being a lot of where I end up
spending time is just you can call me
I'm not in there with your co-founder
and they're with your customers let me
help create frameworks for you to make
decisions
challenging you and then just listen to
you when you need to talk through
whatever is whatever is happening and
then I tell them look completely my job
is to help you with the stuff I'm an
expert in in my industry so help you
raise money help you think through
fundraising strategy help you with all
of these things early and then we'll
switch modes once you hit this product
market fit and start scaling and now you
need to hire an engineering and product
team a lot of teams that I work with
have not hired 10 or 20 engineers and so
like I now have a standing call with one
of my teams that I invested in maybe
three years ago now that's worth a
couple hundred million bucks and they're
like we've got 30 engineers and we're
trying to figure out how to like make
this machine work right it's like great
well now I actually have a useful
concrete skill that I can give to you
that's a team where the engineers are
pretty good maybe you'd hire those
people maybe you wouldn't but that's now
become the bottleneck so early that's I
think as an engineer what you're not
prepared for is like you're not the
bottleneck unless you're really really
bad so it's like getting those muscles
going to learn all the skills you need
to compliment your engineering expertise
I think maybe you said being self-aware
about that right so I try to help people
understand what the benchmarks are going
to be how they're going to be judged
connect them to things so that they can
focus on building their business and I
can be the expert in VC some people
become angel investors just kind of
gradually and organically like someone
they know starts a company and they're
like oh yeah I come in or whatever I
sort of jumped into a full-speed I quit
my job at Facebook and like my goodbye
email I wrote I'm up to be a full-time
angel investor and so like I want to go
from zero to 60
I interviewed every founder I knew I
asked them what was who is your most
valuable angel and what did they do what
was it that they did that was most
viable and the answer was basically
therapy the angel is the one person
they're not an investor who sits on your
board who's basically your boss and you
have to like you know like you should be
very open you can be transparent and
honest with your investors and you can
tell them the things you're worried
about but like in the back of your head
is always like you know this person owns
my fate controls my destiny and and your
employees and your co-founder
it's also deep in academic section your
element trenches together but ultimately
you're the founder CEO all eyes are on
you you know if you sneeze they get a
cold and so the angel is the one person
who sort of like completely outside that
framework and who you can just be honest
with when you're feeling like totally
crappy or you can if you have an angel
with that kind of a relationship and
that was universally the answer I got
from founders that they valued the most
and you know and yeah I got product
strategy advice and business advice and
they introduced some customers and they
introduced some people I could hire and
they helped me was interviewing like I
do all those things but it turns out
therapy and and my own experience now
sort of two and a half years later which
I'm nowhere near the endgame of being
able to say you know that I succeeded at
it but but I can say that that the
founders I think who really valued who
who valued what I gave them the most was
when we had that kind of could have that
kind of therapy relationship I also want
this wasn't the question but I want to
pick up on one thing Trudy said and see
if it she said you know Kay before you
quit your job to start a company like
call up some friends you have who might
buy it and you know if if you're like me
like you might be sitting there in the
audience going like I don't have any
friends who might find my software like
I'm saying he was making software for
lawyers like I don't know any lawyers
like you know what am I supposed to do
if I don't have friends who might buy my
software the answer is don't found that
startup yeah like if you literally know
nobody who's a potential customer like
like for what you might build then you
are not in the right line of business
you should be solving a problem that you
are passionate about and knowledgeable
about and that hopefully means that if
you if you are not yourself a potential
customer of the product like that you at
least know a lot of it yeah or minimum
we don't raise money I mean you were
talking about the top quality life
sciences I had a great call with someone
the other day who is sort of new
socially is like I want to get into the
real estate business and do this crazy
real estate startup and it's kind of an
interesting idea and he said very
self-aware person he's like look I'm
naturally just going to go run this like
a small business and try to do
transactions to so we're having a
theoretical conversation but he's very
aware to be like let me go just try this
see if anybody wants to buy this thing
and then if I can do that then I can
figure out if it's worth turning into a
company and using the answer is no but
you fail cheaply right you do it quickly
you do it on the side
I much you can do that sometimes you
gotta jump all the way in I think that's
actually a really intelligent and
thoughtful way to do it as opposed to
saying you know what I want to start a
startup and so I'm going to pick an idea
and I'm going to go do it that just
never never ends well so this is how we
see sound when they pass in the deal
right it's like those are that company
well there is all these visions of how
engineer receive sound anyway I might
not have caught on to the lingo yet well
I think the the thing that I went
through in myself so one of the things
when you're at a company and I call it
the agitation when you're in that
company when you want to solve problems
but oftentimes they're personal because
you're an engineer and you're using
software that you don't like and you
know you want to find better software
because in your personal time you're
using Facebook and things like that that
are actually pretty and good and then
you're forced to use like William
systems and old things that are bad so
then you go and maybe solve some of that
which you are used to or the other side
of the thing is you're just like
passionate about something like it could
be kind of make up or you just had a
child and you are passionate about that
problem but you don't know anything
about that problem as a business and
that's where I think the difference is
my problem at that time was when I
started pensee was oh I like I like to
talk to a lot of folks I just don't
think it was a good you know serum out
there for me I didn't even know the word
by the way CRM at the time so that's a
problem and and I was going blind doing
something building something and my
co-founder and I were friends from my
master's degrees days at Columbia so we
just kind of learned like really
passionate about it more like of course
that has a problem that people have to
solve but there was no path to having
someone pay for that or a path to like
making like calling friends and saying
who you would you buy this and so that's
a problem those links that were missing
in the middle are the links that I think
I tell a lot of the founders or trying
to be new founders to go solve that
before you go raise money or
is actually we're knowing somebody who
does some investing is really helpful
actually because knowing somebody who
looks at a thousand companies a year
that's a superpower it's somewhat
useless for anything real but like
you're like oh you're trying to do this
thing in this industry let me give you
five examples and let me introduce you
to three people who know some things
about that and you can actually learn a
lot about business models and things
that work and how to make a viable
business and you you often might hear a
bunch of people tell you no and decide
they're all wrong and that's okay but
you can learn pretty cheaply well now
that we know that being an engineer
founder is all sunshine we touched on
meaning therapy and we therapists or at
least life coaches which is sort of the
goin term d'Azur we talked about we
touched on sort of some unique
advantages that folks in the data space
might have in their companies
how should a how should a startup
sort of in the current era think of data
is it is it a sense of defensibility
play is it something you only acquire if
you're successful through data exhaust
is it something you should go out and
try and find unique sources to get a
competitive advantage early on like are
there any rules of thumb in the way a
company a small company should think
about it's sort of the advantage of data
I think there are a few sources of
genuine competitive advantage for
startups in this day and age I think
that the it has become so much easier
and so much cheaper to create a basic
web app a basic mobile app you know a
novel product insight or a business
model insight you know is a competitive
advantage only for as long as it takes
for other people to realize it's
successful and copy it so I think from
day one competition should not
necessarily be your first focus as a
founder but comparative advantage should
be because
you're building something that's easy to
build for two reasons one if you really
have discovered something novel and it's
awesome other people are going to follow
you as soon as that's clear and and and
large people who are much bigger than
you and little will snuff you out but
also it should give you pause on whether
what you're trying to create really
isn't family valuable if it's pretty
easy to build and nobody has done it so
your your goal should be to build
something as hard as possible to explain
why nobody else is build it or that it's
only just now possible so that you can
be confident you really are building
something quite valuable but not
something that just anybody could have
done at any point in the last five years
I mean I would I would say trying to
build easy things assault the way you
create value is solving a real problem
and sometimes you can do that with the
most trivial technology and that's okay
but the world is not full of dumb people
if there are no the true the solutions
are hard problems are rare hey true I
think what would respect to data though
I think we we have this problem today
which reminds me of like the sort of
like when you know Facebook was really
coming up and everybody's like I'm
building a platform it's like no you're
not if you're building a ruby on rails
app with an API that it was going to use
because you have no customers right you
can sort of say like I'm building a data
mode it's like no you're not like you
need to build something that customers
get value from that results in a data
set that creates a competitive advantage
and so I think the challenge of being a
data science you guys have like the most
in-demand skill right but the problem is
that the skill is most useful after you
solve this really hard problem in an
early-stage startup so you guys just are
crazy to start companies because your
comparative advantage is coming into a
company later where you Crale this value
so it's okay to do irrational things but
but you've got to get the first things
right before you can go and get the data
to go get the second things right so I
think that's a that is opinio I mean I
agree with you but I but I think that
there you can absolutely bootstrap your
way to a large data set very very early
right and I think that that is you know
if I sort of if I if I come full circle
on what on where I was going it's
what makes you believe that you alone
can solve this problem and if you are
looking at a world where you are going
to be able to acquire a large amount of
proprietary data that nobody else can
acquire you may be really onto something
and it may be that the way to acquire
that data is to just go have a ton of
customers like Salesforce has tons and
tons of customers so now they have a
data access and they should be able to
do something really really interesting
with it you know Facebook I think you
know really did not start to exploit its
data network effects until 2010 and
beyond I mean I think it was really just
hitting its stride and it was first had
to do something else of value before it
got all these users and then it noticed
that it had this huge data asset and
maybe it should do something but I do
think there are ways to bootstrap that
whether whether it's with public
datasets whether it's with partnerships
whether it's with research whether it's
was like you know the right kind of
partnerships I'm saying Itamar is an
investor in a company called patient
which has a really fascinating way of
acquiring large datasets fast but now if
you want to say more about them
remember securities investor - yes yeah
we're both doctors and patients so so
like Parker are you in a - angel Oh
angel is so so so all of a things if you
how are you if your idea involved it's a
unique and proprietary data set or a
unique way of combined combining and
drawing value from public data sets you
may be really onto something so I don't
think we're disagreeing in that I think
if you're saying hey let's take a public
data set which definitionally is not
defensible right I can take it you could
take it yep but you have the data
science skills to take that like pacer
it's taking the legal legal data stuff
no never submitted I know a different
company called patient please pacer
later I'm sorry yeah yeah I good so you
could use on technology to go and do
something useful but I think people
sometimes give the order of operations
wrong on that I'm so it's like think
about the future because if you show up
at that and you ask hey will you invest
in my company they're going to be
thinking about what your data mode is
five years ago five years from now
they're probably not going to be asking
you well could anybody else build it
today because then they never invest in
it all right you would hope not but I I
mean the two I would look at it two ways
think about a lot
I feel like I'm on par with there's good
data is just with bigger companies now
and so it's harder to start a company
with a differentiation now so what do
you do and my thinking around that is
the one thing we covered here which is a
create partnerships of who wants to
partner with the companies with the new
company that's just coming off the
ground but I've seen folks do that in
creative ways if you have something to
offer people go and if they're not
thinking about their data uniquely which
is rare these days but maybe you can
find somewhere to do it like legal data
or things that are unique the second way
is creating your own data and that's
harder but and that doesn't happen right
away but it's a path to thinking about
your company in a way that is even if
you're like an events platform or
something else it's well if I have this
data and if I have these vendors and all
sorts of other folks using my platform
in the ideal scenario this is the kind
of thing I will create and not five
years from now but like even in six
months because the value of what I'm
offering in return for the data that
gets created is going to be awesome and
so in the old school days of switching
costs and whatever all that is but
that's another way I look at data but
it's true like right now data or
anything to differentiate yourself is
very hard you better like we very
passionate about what you're doing and
just go at it in a very different go to
market way and to make business more
viable and so have customers to pay you
for it
so I think this one is really tough look
I probably like 90% of the investment
deals that I see that the founders are
trying to pitch me some story about
we're going to have this data we're
going to have this EXO state I'm going
to be worth so much money and I'm like
guys this is awesome but the reality is
it's not that easy and a lot of people
have access to this data set and even if
you can create a propriety data set if
you're pitching that this is going to be
so valuable I like show me that value
because a lot of proprietary data sets
don't really have that value and they
don't have really to have a market that
you can sell that data you know you can
leverage the data
love you know opportunity so I think in
sometimes I see companies focused on you
know building tools to you know crunch
process distribute data right I'm an
investor in a bunch of companies that
you know use data in personalization and
online advertising and stuff like that
and and I know how value can be created
by exchanging data there but the truth
is for the vast majority of startups
having data is not a valuable right and
it's it's not good it's not a
possibility well and you you may not
know what the data is going to be I
think if you don't know what the problem
is you're ultimately going to solve for
the customer you don't know what the
data is it's going to fall out of that
and if you don't know what data you're
going to have you can't really talk
about how much value you can create out
of it so that becomes an emergent
property of solving a customer's problem
so I I personally like early I think
would be by the series a you kind of had
these things figured out generally
speaking you're like look we've got this
big data set we're solving a customer
like I have a company I just invested in
it's got a phenomenal data set three
years ago when they started this thing
they actually they were still working
with the same customer trying to solve
problems but they would have had no idea
that the data set that they've created
today would have been something that
would have fallen out of solving the
problem that they ultimately found so
they ended up with something valuable
they could have gone into Vedant it's
that three years ago at the epicene so I
think that that ends up being
challenging as well sometimes you you
don't know where you're going to end up
on these things yeah it also ends up
being sort of a secondary sort of
revenue line for a company that's more
mature versus this is the primary thing
that we mean Google by the way the
classic example of this like who would
have thought that they would have
invented the best advertising model of
all time being people who hated
advertising just they built a great
product and then one day they were like
Hobbes put ads right here yeah it seems
like often data is the byproduct of
having a certain amount of success
that's solving a customer problem I mean
there are exceptions to that but but you
have to focus on solving a customer's
problem first if you somehow have access
to novel data
that you can use to do that fine but
those opportunities are becoming
increasingly rare it seems more often
than not it's the data exhaust that's
thrown off by a successful traction that
actually becomes you know it's a
byproduct of success the first step
seems to me I would say for folks here
who work with a lot of data and think of
yourself as a buyer and if you're
encountering problems that are stopping
you from making efficiency harm
including your efficiency or
productivity in all the things you're
doing in your job today and you would be
willing to pay for something a lot like
a lot of amount to pay for something
that can make your life better and
accelerate the company yard working at
faster that's a problem you've uncovered
and then if you should and then you have
your peers right here who would buy that
- that's other customers and then you
are positioned to solve a problem and go
start a company if you really want to go
start a company in that category no one
else is solving that problem that's
that's one way to look at that I look in
data I love your focus on people buying
stuff true caring it's like a gravity a
recurring theme and it's something that
needs to be well understood by the
audience because it's super easy to live
in your little engineering glass castle
and want to build some technical
solution to some problem and really
these way too far behind the curve in
proving to yourself let alone investors
that someone will actually pay money for
the product just to add to that I mean I
think something you will find is that
you know I feel like we are with respect
to data science where we were with
mobile 10 years ago where anybody with
the skill set can go get a couple
million dollars which is kind of bad in
the sense that you're like well if
somebody gave me millions of dollars I
must have a good idea this must be
special and it's sort of a false
positive there whereas your customers
wanting to buy things is actually real
and I think that you know that people
get caught up in that right like
somebody wants to give them money and
that person giving the money is giving
money to 30 other people and it's the
surge it's like well if this doesn't
work out you guys are really smart we'll
sell you and I'll get my money back so
it's a little bit of money for them
many years of pain and suffering for you
and so don't you know these aren't
smarter than you to find the customers
and figure it out with them we can end
on that note aware so take them money so
let's take a couple questions from the
audience who who has a burning desire to
ask a question : oh we got one here so
I'm pretty big and if you check out my
investments I'm pretty bullish on
background location data I know it's not
a new thing but it really is I believe
the offline cookie right it's the best
way to represent what actually happens
on the ground we're really really good
at understanding what's happening online
right people are going the websites or
clicking they're using a mobile app we
know how to track whole debt we know how
to answer and understand what they are
up to based on that but we don't know a
whole lot about what's happening on the
ground so so that's that's a really big
one that I personally like yeah I mean I
think there's you know I think the
arrival of IOT this is not a novel thing
to say but the arrival of IOT means
we're getting just absolute floods of
sensor data and so there are these areas
that I would say in the past had been
data deserts they've been data starved
like you know limited by our human
perception and reasoning and where now
we can really bring you know machine
intelligence to bear on those areas
agriculture is one that is really
interesting to me because we've started
to get a lot of penetration with IOT
we're starting to get you know soil and
humidity soil humidity and temperature
and you know sort of climate centers
those are all out there and but but by
and large you've just getting raw data
to the farmer to try to make better
decisions himself I think that is like a
very clear opportunity to to bring
machine intelligence to bear you know
where else are we starting to have
ubiquitous
there's like security cameras you know
just sort of cities they're starting to
have cameras everywhere
you know transportation everybody's
thinking about self-driving cars but but
just what about better city planning
because we know where this is sort of on
the location to do stuff but we know
where the traffic is we know where the
parking spaces are open we know where
the foot traffic is like can we design
cities better because we understand how
people are moving through them you know
I think healthcare very very obviously
it's where all of a sudden we're about
to have sort of orders of more magnitude
of data like you know there are millions
of MRIs and CT scans like lying around
and repositories can we suck them in and
learn something from them about
diagnosing disease undoubtedly so I feel
like I think there's there's insane
sources of like untapped you know it's
like this this crude oil in the ground
just waiting to be tapped as a terrible
analogy but you know it's treasure
waiting to be mined and refined and
turned into something valuable so yes I
mean I I think I take sort of everything
sucks philosophy on startups like
there's problems everywhere there's
problems to be solved every really like
you know you have this great New Yorker
cartoon that's like two cavemen sitting
there going like oh you know he invented
the wheel when he invented fire there's
nothing last right
there's just problems everywhere and I
take it I take a very bottoms-up
approach my assumption is this like if I
can think of the problem that's not a
very interesting problem what I would
like is for you to walk in and blow my
mind with something that you figured out
that I've never thought of and those are
the things that get me excited and so
that can be on the data side it can also
be on the algorithm side for example I
invested in a company called new Mirai
that's really interesting
data sort of they use a really
interesting kind of encryption to give
data scientists the ability to take open
datasets and come up with trading
algorithms and then they use those
algorithms to trade and pay people out
in bitcoins so they've got people
sitting around the world figuring out
how to beat the market like that's just
a problem I never would have thought of
and it's not per se a data problem right
they've solved the data problem to solve
a business problem so they've aggregated
all these open datasets and encrypted in
such a way that people can play with
them you should all
do this and make a bunch of money but I
just I don't I would never have thought
of that right I'm just not out there in
the world in the trenches and I think
there was an earlier point made about
like finding problems that are relevant
to you that's where you have a
comparative advantage over someone else
great well we're out of time
unfortunately but if you have more
questions our gentle panelists will be
around later
I believe so thank you guys that was a
fun conversation thanks for coming
thanks for having us thanks addy
[Applause]